à voir l'agriculture a porté de ville
avec un équilibre entre zones agricoles
et zones urbaines
c'est le principe des territoires agri
orban la thématique d'un séminaire
organisé par l'association patrimoniale
de la plaine de versailles
je pense qu'il est indispensable à
l'heure actuelle dans notre société de
pouvoir maintenir des équilibres entre
et bien les urbains et les agriculteurs
au programme notamment une table ronde
sur les facteurs d'attractivité des
territoires agrio bain dans les grandes
métropoles avec des retours d'expérience
de montréal genève ou encore milan du
côté je né vois les cultures sont
maraîchères et viticole l'agriculture
milanaise elle s'appuie sur les céréales
et le riz nos forces réside dans une
profession qui tient à garder
une lien très fort avec la terre qui
veut pouvoir nourrir la population
il y avait quand même des actions
publiques pour mettre en valeur la
filière
sur notamment la filière du riz qui est
produit localement transformer
localement est vendu en vente directe
sur la plaine de versailles
l'association patrimoniale créé en 2004
permet des échanges entre trois groupes
les élus les agriculteurs et la société
civile
le principe c'est que on vient
accompagner les projets par une bonne
confiance entre les élus et le monde
agricole
c'est dans ces conditions qu'une
douzaine de jeunes agriculteurs se sont
installés dans la plaine de versailles
sur ces trois dernières années